so i spoke to you a couple of months ago
it was zoom so happy to see you in
person
how are you feeling now that you're here
people are seeing clips of the movie
yeah so this is the first time the
trailer is going to be shown to a group
of people uh we we screen the movie in
front of 400 people in los angeles but
now that this is kind of getting out and
see the reaction of people it's
interesting you know especially being a
stand-up comedian
showing a movie you really have no
control of kind of what they're laughing
at because it's already set in stone so
it's a new experience for me and i'm
enjoying every minute of it okay good i
have to ask has your dad's in the movie
yet
no with my father he's very critical of
everything i do
so uh you know until the movie is kind
of locked and loaded
i don't want to show them i want them to
see it in the theater i don't want them
to see it at home
um but my dad has a lot of opinions and
i'm sure i'm going to hear about them
okay so are you going to be freaking out
when this movie premieres for the first
time
for your dad well my dad uh was on set
with us giving de niro uh you know notes
on how to be a hairdresser
so he's kind of like tied into this
whole thing and uh yeah when it comes
out i hopefully i get to see it with him
or maybe it's a better idea maybe he
sees it alone
because my dad has a weird thing of uh
like he'll see his show and if he
doesn't say anything after the show i
know he didn't like it so that's my
indicator strong reaction okay so on a
scale of one to ten how are robert de
niro's hair styling skills now that your
dad taught him
based on what i saw in the movie he's
pretty dead on i mean uh yeah he uh he
does a die job in the movie and the way
he was moving his fingers was
reminiscent of my father so uh
yeah he took it pretty seriously
this is such an incredible cast i mean
robert de niro alone but all of you guys
are so funny what was the vibe like on
set like who's the first one to break
scene
um so the vibe on set for me i had a lot
of anxiety
yeah it wasn't uh
you know i'm a comedian i wasn't like
cracking jokes i was just worried about
is that a child in vegas yes i've seen a
few of them now
yeah so for me i was really honed in on
just wanting to get my lines right or
trying to find a funny moment so i
wasn't really like fun on set i was
working with arguably one of the
greatest actors of our time and i don't
do this day in and day out so
i was sweating yeah yeah but robert de
niro was great
he was excellent i mean i learned a lot
from him there's a scene in the movie
where i get emotional and i never got
emotional on on camera and he kind of
walked me through that so yeah it's
it was difficult for me but uh after
seeing the movie i was like oh wow this
is this is pretty uh
neat to see how it all comes together so
because while you're doing it you don't
know how this is going to be weaved
together so it was interesting being
taught by a legend had a cry uh on
camera that's amazing yes similar to the
one you hear here yeah we gotta find
this baby